families come in all shapes and sizes an
Alaskan Wildlife Conservation staff form
tight bonds with the creatures in their
care hi sweetie Rescuers are just as
invested as any parent oh no C coming
dedicated to helping their animals
Thrive you did such a good job
[Music]
mister
the trains Roll by awcc twice a
day and every time they go by they get a
howl from the
Wolves we're home to Native Alaskan
Wildlife that are rescued injured and
orphaned at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center rescued animals form
connections with both their caretakers
and each other so the Wolves at awcc are
kind of an interesting story deska and
Bri are half sisters and they came from
another facility and then we kind of got
a magical phone call from another
facility that was looking to place two
males dearest the white wolf and
letharia the Blackwolf as soon as the
girls met the boys it was kind of love
at first sight and they've been a really
awesome pack
together lothario is kind of the lead
male and desa's the top
female and just like any household the
mom runs the show
so lethar being that Top Male they
really love to put their muzzle inside
his mouth and for a wolf that's
basically equivalent for a kid comes
home from school and they run up to Mom
and Dad and give a
hug
lario we are going to blow some Bubbles
at the wool today for a little bit of
enrichment for them hi kids living in
human care we don't want them to get
bored want them always using their brain
so we do just different fun things for
them there he go and we switch it up so
sometimes it's just random things like
blowing bubbles at them
cuz bubbles are not something they see
every day it's a new smell it's a new
object so they kind of have to figure
out what it is and they get to have a
little bit of fun with it
too oh there we
[Music]
go oh good job Bri get oh good job
they're usually a lot more playful in
the morning so they're just like really
excited to see us it went well
and Seward staff at the Alaska sea life
center step into a caretaking role for a
baby in need we had quite a busy weekend
got a call on an otter in Homer uh
wildfires are preventing it from getting
here working on what we can do if the
road doesn't open
today this young sea otter was kind of
being beat up by the surf on a beach in
Homer this poor little thing pretty much
looked like a drowned at it was in
pretty rough
shape but with the wildfires that are
burning the road is closed and so we've
made arrangements with a local that was
willing to fly over to Homer for us with
somebody on our staff and pick up this
otter yeah you
swee you are so adorable goodness sakes
I was very excited to see her for the
first time she was very blonde which is
a little unusual all right
kids for an
adventure oh my my God it's not unusual
for a mother seot and her pup to get
separated uh because the mother might be
swimming down getting some food and the
pup could just be swiming around on top
waiting for Mom to come back hi baby
this situation was a little different
because the water was so rough and they
were separated for so long it's okay
baby baby SE OTS they need constant care
from their mothers they cannot be alone
for very long they have a very high
metabolism and it is is risky for them
to not be fed frequently CU their blood
glucose level will go dangerously low
and they can get severely dehydrated
pretty quickly oh my God then she just
fell right asleep and she slept for
almost a whole hour
flight we named this the otter Cinder
because of the forest
fires some sea otters are considered
endangered at this time so it is really
critical for us to learn as much as we
can about them when she arrived at the
sea life center we check her blood
glucose to make sure that that's in a
normal range no can you write down 92
please we also gave her some subq fluids
to make sure she's staying well hydrated
does she have a bottle ready she doesn't
but I get this otter pup is only a week
old and normally they stay with their
mother for 6 months and it's a critical
window right now we're just going to see
how she
does go to sleep low
one the unique bonds formed at
conservation centers help ensure the
survival of important Native Alaskan
species here at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center we've got just about
17 species here with just over 100
animals that call awcc home we've got
anything from black bears to Moose to
porcupine but we're really proud of our
wood bison
herd t 15 years ago there was no wood
bison on the landscape in Alaska they
were extinct from the state in the early
1900s so we reintroduced them with the
Alaska Department of fishing game a few
years ago we were able to grow the herd
and release 130 wood bison back into the
wild this herd that's still at awcc is
part of an active breeding program every
calf that's born here is another chance
to see the wild population
grow got to feed the boys this morning
come
on so here comes the big
boss he's going to be this year's
breeder boy he's
grumpy we work with the state to figure
out which bowl is going to be bred every
year they're all tagged so we can keep
track of who's breeding
when for genetic diversity and just
overall health we need to make sure
we're rotating out
bowls
this year bll 299 gets the luck with the
ladies he's the dominant bull out of all
the Bulls we have he's got a reputation
and it's not the greatest and he gets
testy look he's got his tail up he's
like get out of here I want that
[Applause]
[Music]
bull the plan for tomorrow is to make
sure we can get the last Year's breed
bolt and cut him off from the girls then
we can get 299 in there to do his thing
and hopefully he'll get the job
done in Seward the team already has a
new baby to
raise Cinder The rescued otter pup needs
round the-clock
care this is our second otter pup of the
Season she came to us from Homer and
right now she's just chewing on an ice
cube
her teeth are coming in she's in a
little bit of pain so that's kind of
helping numb um her
gums a she lost her ice cube Jess she
needs some help I'm falling and I can't
get up here flip back over here we
go
there all is right
again Cinder has a very feisty
personality uh she's learning very
quickly so she wants to have things in
her mouth and she wants to explore more
today we're going to be doing one of our
normal feeds with her and we're also
going to be taking a blood glucose
reading so I don't want to get bit you
got little sharp teeth um it's important
for us to help monitor her overall
health make sure she doesn't have a
sugar drop or
anything and you're done how is that 75
that's
okay yeah oh you want your ice cube back
Co oh okay so let's get you
fed yeah it's bottle time hey this this
is what you want wa sea out pups they're
used to being held all the time by their
mothers so it's comforting for them to
be held by
us best part of her
day and the best part of mine
too it does take a lot of effort to keep
them healthy just like a human baby
we're all done
they need to be fed they need help going
to the bathroom they need to be groomed
um so it is a lot of effort a lot of
work on our part a little otter burrito
oh it's the very
cutest even the older animals need
constant care and maintaining close
relationships keeps everyone
[Music]
safe
we just got a radio call that one of the
Wolves deska she's our older female wolf
look like she might have an injury kind
of on her shoulder so we're going to go
check that
out we are going to make sure that it is
something that's not too serious that
doesn't need immediate vet care make
sure she's going to be okay gate we
don't like to go in with all four wolves
so we're put the boys in the lock Downs
on the side just to keep them separated
down the girl girls came in when they
were puppies and they they grew up with
shondel and I since they were babies and
so we're kind of considered a part of
their
pack that being said when an animal is
in pain or injured you know we might see
responses that we normally wouldn't see
oh boy
mhm we're looking at deska she's our
older female wolf not quite sure exactly
what caused the the patch of missing
fur hi baby girl they're still wild
animals they're not friendly they're not
domesticated they are a dangerous
animal we need to get photos so I can
send it to our vet and she can let us
know what she thinks what is that that's
what' you do hey what's that dasa's
thing does not look like a bite there is
no laceration at all it's literally just
plucked hair
yeah it looks like her hair was just
kind of ripped out oh baby girl she's
scratching it we're not really too sure
what happened to
deska kind of seems like a little bit of
a mystery but we need to figure it
out uh cuz if she hurt herself in the
pen we need to fix it so it doesn't
continue to
happen so Sarah and I are going to go
check the fences right now see if
there's anything she could have gotten
caught on anything that we need to fix
uh to make sure we keep those guys
[Music]
safe
so Sarah Bri has a spot I'm sorry a what
on her hip missing first oh boy
mhm seeing Bri with a puncture wound in
her back leg kind of changed the game
for what we think might be going
on might have been kind of a I'm in a
challenge you situation and Bri grabbed
her on the back of the neck like that
and Desa put her in her place and nipped
her you know if she happened to grab
deska by the Scruff and and deska turned
and told her no don't do that kind of
makes sense where the where the injuries
are on the girls especially where that
puncture is that's like a I'm going to
get you kind of thing right so I'm going
to just try to get close to deska to see
how she's doing and if she'll allow me
to I'm going to spray some antibiotics
on
her hi baby
girl hi can I put some of this on you
can I put some of that on you like
that can and see if we can put some
Salve on her that hopefully will help
get that wound healing
quickly it's risky just because she
still has her mouth right there she can
turn around if it hurts that bad um even
though she trust shandelle there's still
that risk okay okay I know I'm sorry
she's like lady what are you why would
you do that
me desk is the top female and Bri is the
punk little sister that can't take a
hint hi naughty wolf did you pick fights
that you shouldn't have huh you are the
Troublemaker huh there is any kind of
fighting or challenging going on we're
going to have to really keep an eye on
them and separate him if we need to you
go hey Natty wolf but we really don't
want to keep them too separate or change
the Dynamics of the pack so um the
quicker we make sure that it doesn't
escalate the
[Music]
better keeping the family strong is
vital to the growth of the Bison herd in
Portage but to do that staff need their
breeding bll to cooperate so we had some
issues with the storm kind of putting a
hold on our plans to move bll
299 you know every year we're breeding
these
animals we still like to see babies
every year uh eventually knowing that
those guys might end up out in the wild
at some
point all right let's go get it
done we've done this move with B 299
before it's been a significant number of
years and this could get
[Music]
Rowdy bll 299 is a bit stubborn I'm
going to have to get behind him and work
him a little
bit we're kind of constantly dealing
with tidal influx and so our pens
actually have a bunch of really big tide
guts which I almost nailed so that got a
little
sketchy on that side of the field he's
on the other side of the tide gut and
she can't get across that and we need to
push him from
there come on
Bon come on bud uh I don't like to run
these guys that much especially cuz
they're over 2,000 lbs right a big
animal like that moving that's a lot of
energy and stress but you got to keep
him moving so he keeps moving we were
going between 15 M an hour and 20 I'm
going to let him walk I'm going to push
him if we don't get on this try we're
done come on
bud come
on
this is the last try just so everybody
knows bull 299 he's kind of running
around a little bit more than I want him
to I don't want to stress this big guy
out if this doesn't work out we're going
to call it tonight and we'll come back
again and regroup and try
again I feel like we kind of had this
moment we looked at each other he knew
what I wanted cuz he immediately looked
at that gate opening and realized oh I'm
supposed to go this way good boy come
on go on get up on the road get up on
the road Bud coming around the corner
it's been almost 4 years since he's been
in that pasture so it took him a hot
minute to figure out which gate to go
through which is why he kind of kept
going in circles with me my crew nailed
it they all waved their hands they made
themselves look big and he went down the
right path that we wanted him to go
down good boy good boy get the gate they
look really big and kind of binka dink
uh but man once they start moving those
four legs they can really haul some
tail good boy I am very excited with how
this move went today once B 299 came
around that corner and saw his ladies he
was super stoked and the girls were all
super excited for the new man on the
Block so everything worked out for
everybody the whole family's together
[Music]
again after weeks at the seaa Life
Center it's time for young otter Cinder
to leave the rescue but for cinder's
adoptive parents letting her go isn't
easy oh my gosh wow hungry has like a
pocket full of crab too how is that
Cinder has been here and the last 3
weeks she has learned that she can swim
you want your
clam she likes to swim on her belly
which most of them swim on their back so
she has learned that she can bite things
she loves to play she moves around a lot
more than she used
to it's very exciting for us to watch
her grow and to learn and just to see
her
improving we need your clam good girl
she is learning to like solid foods it's
still new to her yeah it's so tasty
Cinder will not be able to be released
back into the wild because she was
brought into the rehab so young and she
did not learn any proper SKS from her
mother she just wouldn't be able to
survive on her own go to sleep little
[Music]
one soon Cinder will be leaving us to go
to Southern California to ear new a
permanent home Cinder is now going to be
a Ambassador for her species and it's a
great opportunity for folks to be able
to see
otters I'll be sad when Cinder does
leave us and especially so short
normally they stay with us a little bit
longer but she's doing well and it will
give us room for new Waters to come into
rehab at the awcc staff prep medication
for their injured wolves but first it's
feeding time for an elderly Alaskan
animal come on Nelson hey you guys all
came in a good time yeah today the Moose
are going to get their favorite treat
which is some Willow brows so they're
eating Willow right now n
moose sir this is going to be our best
opportunity to give Nelson some meds
banana moose are pretty big suckers for
anything in a banana but when it comes
to the carnivores you have to disguise
it a little bit better cuz if they smell
it at all they're just going to spit
that piece of meat
out two of our wolves our females got
injured got into a little bit of a
bickering match this morning the plan is
to get Desa and breather second round of
meds uh they need four pills a day for
the next few
days hi kids Dash you going to come over
Bri thankfully came right in but it's
like where's
deska I'm just going to be fine we were
calling her and didn't she wasn't in
that kind of triggered a little panic in
all of us figure out what was going on
normally that'll get her Bri was
thankfully able to take the meat from
Austin he was able to get that to her
Des deska because her inju is a little
bit worse than Breeze and it's going to
be pretty important that she gets those
meds I'm getting pretty worried I'm
going to get with shondelle and then
we're going to head in there and see
what we can find hi Bri
Bri most of the time as soon as ASA
hears shond Del's voice she's at the
fence ready for
attention I
don't sort of almost feel like we should
stay together
maybe cuz even though they've been
raised by us we just need to be you know
just each other's backers when we're in
there with Wolves of
course
dashka dash
dash fre Bri what' you do Dash where are
you dash you're killing me
man
Dash Dash
Dash daska um we're just looking for
deska right now at this
point it's concerning cuz when
shandell's here and I'm here normally
she always wants to come up and say hi
so behaviorally something is off I would
feel better if you just would not creep
up behind me please there is an injury
uh which means we're not going to get
normal behavior we're going to get
something different uh so we just need
to be safe for everybody in
involved
deska there's a lot of dens that the
wolves have built in the pens deska do
she probably went into one of her holes
and she's not coming out that's for darn
sure let the boys out that's usually our
Sure Fire option uh is to let the boys
back out they're always really excited
to be back together you guys ready to go
outside G
gate we're going to try to kind of do a
group howl and maybe she'll come out for
that really get the Wolves amped up and
they'll all start howling and hopefully
desko will pop
out Kim we're going to try howling see
if it'll bring her
[Music]
out and we're howling and we're howling
and nothing's
happening and she finally came out of
the hole was a huge sigh of relief when
she finally came out of her
den and thankfully she was motivated and
she wanted to eat uh so we were able to
give her the
meds cool she got them des's wound looks
really good it's starting to kind of
heal on its own a little
bit just really watch these guys cuz
when one of them's hurt like that they
just get testy with each other
so
boy lario actually kind of went right
after Deus he wouldn't he didn't want
him to get close to
deska and he kind of just flipped him
over and put him down and let him know
that you need to stop this is over I'm
protecting my woman whining you hear it
yep
Dash they're going to pick on her Desa
started scratching cing and she started
whining and because she's kind of the
lead female uh to be vulnerable and
injured the way she is everybody got
really worked up cuz they didn't
understand why she was doing that cuz
nobody was doing anything to her
lothario got a little amped up she
couldn't tell why he was getting behind
her like that so she was
vulnerable it's going to be an
interesting Dynamic going over the next
couple days there's some hierarchy
changes maybe happening um which means
more fighting could potentially
happen we just really need to watch
their interaction with each
other in Seward it's time for staff to
say goodbye to their baby
otter all right here you go
babe you ready for your big
adventure you're no stranger to
planes today we're transporting C to her
new home in
[Music]
California with younger otters we can't
release them because mom takes such good
care of
them that's just something we can't
replace so the younger ones they become
ambassadors baby I'm going to miss you
be good girl he says okay you come visit
me you be a good girl I hope so it is
sad to see Cinder go I have created a
little bit of a bond with her but I know
that she's going to a great place and
and she's going to be well cared for and
that's the whole reason why we're here
is so that we can bring new animals in
care for them and then see them go off
to their new home and and
Thrive there are a lot of people that go
into helping an otter from the people
who report the otter the people who pick
it up here at the sea life center when
they're with us it's 24/7 care so
there's a lot of people supporting that
it takes a village to raise an
[Music]
otter for every animal who leaves the
rescue there's a new one in need so the
Alaska Wildlife Conservation Center
staff has prepared for their newest
additions we have three or four cows
that might have a baby we should be
expecting Cals any day so we got to be
checking on them every hour or
[Music]
so wood bison were once extinct from the
state so it's really important to keep
the breeding
going come on kids Come on
B you sound like a broken air horn let's
see how you do it come on come on kids
they can't even hear you in the back
they already know you know I've been
here for about 10 years and that's
really how I got my first gig here with
the Wildlife Center was caring for all
these wood bis and these animals are are
pride and
joy hi sweetie the biggest signs that me
and the team look out for every day when
we're checking on the herd is just to
see if any cows are starting to single
themselves out I say I've been watching
them lately I say they've all been
hanging out as a herd yeah nobody's
really separating themselves huh
drinking lots of water cuz it's nice and
hot out so as Hof stock keeper I'm
pretty much just in charge of monitoring
everyone I like to spend a little bit
more extra time out here make sure their
water's chopped off food's good to go
I'm pretty excited just to see these
Cals just because they really kind of
just became my most favorite animal here
so next week
though I got something to talk to you
about
I'm actually going out to fly over the
wild
herd get to see your babies again to see
all my babies growing up in the wild
awcc has been working with the state to
be reintroduced the wood bison into the
Alaska we were able to grow the herd
from you know 13 animals to 155 is and
we released 130 of them in the
wild getting the opportunity to go out
and see the wild herd is the most
exciting opportunity to
have it's I can't even describe how it
feels but it's really
cool but it's also kind of stressful
time to leave the Wildlife Center during
the peak of
summer so while I'm out of town the
wildlife center and the Bison in
particular are kind of in John's hands
he's pretty quick on his feet so I'm
confident that he'll be just fine I
think a calf is pretty
[Music]
imminent so just did my final drive
around for the evening and I noticed
that Cal 336 uh she's laying against the
fence and she kind of looked like she
had a swollen back in there we might
have a calf on the
[Music]
way she probably just wants to lay down
and do her own
thing all signs that we're going might
have a baby bison here
[Music]
soon
good
boy I'm packing for my trip going to go
look at some wild bison for the first
time in four years since they've been
released so I'm pretty stoked and so is
my
dog last night I really thought we were
going to have a calf on the ground and
apparently she's just toying with me uh
so of course as soon as I get to the
airport main cridge my staff will
probably call me it's just one night
rigs it's hardly in the animals at any
given time whether it's a bison or
anybody else but knowing that there's
some bison ready to calf it's hard to
walk away from it but at the same time I
get to go see the wild bison which has
been a goal of mine since they've been
released so it's kind of a give and
take good thing I grabbed
it doesn't want you to take my
tee the cing season upon us and the heat
wave that we've got going on I'm just
hoping everything's going to be fine
while I'm
gone for some animals parenting comes
naturally but at the sea life center one
pair of love birds needs a little extra
help so our exhibit is designed here to
look like a natural Rookery in the wild
we've got 11 species out here most
people come to see the puffins puffins
are widespread in Alaska but they're
really hard to study because they're bur
nesters and live in holes in the
rocks and we've created Burrows
here we have a number of corn Puffin
pears that breed each summer they do
mate for life so once a pear bond is
formed they'll come back to the same
mate year after year after year but this
summer at the beginning of the breeding
season there was a bit of drama with one
of our puffing pairs rain and
copper copper decided she wanted to
maybe pair with somebody else this year
so rain got kind of ousted from The Nest
site and just moped around looking kind
of like sad and disheveled until he
decided one day that that was enough
which caused a big fight in the exhibit
and Rain won the battle so he got to
stay with
copper so in order to reinforce this
pear Bond we're letting them hatch and
raise a chick this
year hello sir can I please have your
egg we have another pair of puffins with
a really valuable egg genetically that
we'd really like to hatch but the
parents don't usually take care of their
chicks very well the last time we let
them hatch a chick and try to raise it
they didn't feed the chick and so we
ended up having to hand ra it ourselves
so we decided to pull their egg and give
them a fake
egg we go through all the eggs that are
laid here and we can tell if they're
fertile or
not
awesome this is the embryo developing
right here this is the red crisp veining
that looks really healthy and this is
the Yol discing along the bottom of
where the embryo is developing it's
totally alive and looks very
healthy all right so we're going to go
and give this valuable egg to copper and
take her egg
out are you okay with this
rain yeah I know this is really rough
business and the Avary are connected to
these nest boxes behind the scenes where
we can keep an eye on the puffins and
their
nests hi copper can you please take this
one thank you so hopefully he'll accept
that new egg and incubate it for us and
raise the
chick good boy sir thank you you are so
patient while we gave you a new
egg and I'm sure you'll do a great job
you want one more mhm
H the wolf pack proves that even the
closest families clash and in time make
up we're about to go feed the Wolves for
the
morning few more days of their
antibiotics what we think happened is
Bri decided she was going to step up hi
Dash zesa is our top female so Bri just
made a power play uh I think it kind of
shook things up a little bit in our
pack gate
here wolves are very social animals that
was a really weird social event that
happened so they're still rebounding
their relationship with each other so
there's a lot of patience that we have
to
have Des do come on lady Lou stand the
really awesome thing about having them
here is when stuff like that happens we
can be on it getting them that
medication or cream or whatever they
need to help prevent any sort of extra
pain or
discomfort right now now they're a
stable pack which is a happy
pack the wolf pack is very near and dear
to my heart uh especially deska Des GES
uh when you work in Animal Care not
supposed to have favorites I totally
have favorites and the wolves are are
[Music]
them back at the sea life center the
newest Puffin chick could arrive at any
moment oh should we check on rain's egg
yeah yeah all right we are about to
check on the egg that rain and copper
are sitting on it's due to hatch in a
couple days it has pipped so there was a
little crack on it when I checked
yesterday I'm expecting to have just a
little bit of progress
today hi sweetie I'm going to open the
little box here we check it every day
because during the hatching process
there's a lot of things that could go
wrong usually if an egg is going to die
it's going to die really early in
incubation or right at the end while
while it's trying to hatch
[Music]
out so I'm opening up the door to the
burrow box to check on the egg that rain
and copper are sitting
on oh it
hatched there's a chick oh my goodness
hi sweetie I that's why rain's been in
such a mood
today oh it is fresh too oh my goodness
Mama good job I know we're just going to
go process your chick okay and then I'll
give it back I promise oh wait no you're
getting cold don't worry we'll keep this
fast it's a brand new chick so it's
going to get chilly uh pretty quickly so
I knew we didn't have that much time to
process the chick but we wanted to take
its first initial measurements what do
you 5 69
nice oh so now we're just going to check
its
umbilicus which is still swallen that's
his little belly
button now we're going to put this
little guy back with Mom and Dad copper
is a great mom and rain is uh sometimes
not the best puff and Dad but this year
I think he's so excited to have copper
back in his life hey rain but I'm quite
positive he'll be a number one dad just
to show off to Copper I saw you have a
chick you did such a good job
Mister you go take care of your little
baby good
[Music]
boy when it's time for kids to leave the
nest parents have to adjust but bonds
remain no matter the distance so today I
get the opportunity of lifetime I get to
fly over the wild wood bison herd that I
was able to help raise before awcc grew
the herd to 130 bison wood bison were
actually extinct in Alaska so here we
are four years later I get to go check
on the wild wood bison herd with Tom
seatan who works with the Alaska
Department of fishing game are you ready
to go see the Bison I am ready to go see
bison good yes I've never done this
before oh really yeah I don't want to
come across like I'm a high school girl
that just got asked to prom but I'm
getting to go bison so just trying to
keep it
chill the inoko is in the western part
of the state There's No Buses there's no
roads there's no street lights it's the
perfect place for wood bison to
grow coming around that corner in that
helicopter
was I was speechless I can't I don't
know how to describe
looking at something that you've been
working for for so long if you don't
know what you're looking at they'll just
look like little brown dots but I
immediately felt Overjoyed cuz oh my
gosh there's the Bison they're right
there and we're going to land
there bison you know they're they're
Wanderers and so they just kind of
naturally split up into their own
[Music]
groups bison are really important for
the ecosystem they do a lot of things
that help all animals from top to
bottom this is a little outside of most
people's comfort zone for
sure it's like this for hundreds of
square miles and if you go far enough
tens of thousands of square miles of
just man grass country out
here just following Tom into the
abyss whole new respect for what he has
to do for the love of wood
bison it's really good habitat for bison
and the animals that live there um but
as far as human inhabitants it's
definitely
it's rough you're constantly going
between all the the swampy marshy parts
then you have grassland so it's like a
mix of everything in between
kumbuk this is
awful these bugs you can't open your
mouth without eating 10 of them I
thought Portage was bad Portage ain't
got nothing on the inoco the bison are
just up around this corner about 2 300
yard so we'll just look a body condition
and see how the Cals are doing things
like done
[Music]
okay there you go oh look at them here's
what all your hard work turned into
yeah look at all those
babies so close to half of the
population is wild Born now but uh you
can still see some ear tags from animals
that you took care of back that's pretty
cool isn't
it wow they look
good what's really neat is at this
little group there's almost 14 15 Cals
and they were all fat plump and orange
so little round pumpkins out
there an't it cool to see them in the
wild and just like it was like the way
it would be right today was probably
like easily the top day in my last 10
years hands
down he didn't catch my tears but they
were
there he just kind of cmin all the work
that everybody put into us all those
years ago and to see the herd doing
really well that's so freaking
cool I have Soggy Bottom britches I have
been eaten
alive and I would do it all again if
that meant I got to go see Wildwood
[Music]
bison I've been pretty much Off the Grid
since yesterday afternoon when we
arrived and I haven't heard a peep from
my folks down at the Wildlife Center
just got to hope that John's got the
herd handled back there in case there's
any babies being
born so hopefully everything's going
okay back in Portage Sarah's anxious to
check in with the
herd it's first light I'm going to go
check on that cow and see if she gave
birth
[Music]
yet oh
yeah oh little cat's
coming it's pretty pretty sweet look at
your little baby what a cutie we've been
waiting for this for a while so now for
it to actually happen everyone's really
excited I want to see
the it's going to the
bathroom standing like it's a
[Music]
boy I think it might be I think that's a
boy little
baby we are like 75% certain it's a boy
right now we're just going to keep
observing they're pretty much
independent from us it's just pretty
much wait and see what
happens at the sea life center Aviary
the puffins keep staff on their
toes rain has been spending most of his
day defending the nest site so he stands
in front of their burrow entrance and he
head tosses is and kind of Puffs off his
chest to make sure everybody knows like
don't come in this area there's
something really important in this
burrow that he's taking care of and
copper is doing a really good job
sitting with the chick most of the day
and keeping it really
warm this is a really busy time of year
in our Avary and for our bird
staff we have birds that are hatching we
have birds that are still incubating
eggs and because we have birds that are
often uh Territorial and can be rather
aggressive you really have to monitor
Behavior as well here we go so these
guys are first time parents so we're
just kind of watching this chick extra
closely but they're doing a very good
job sometimes I come out to weigh the
chicks and the glove that I use is a
really thick glove uh but it's a orange
colored glove so they know when I have
that big orange glove on most likely I'm
coming out to look at their chicks and
weigh their chicks and they don't like
that so they get really angry at the
glove and try to attack the glove
usually that's the glove there we
go all right
kiddos oh Lou I here oh that was very
rude
sir naughty so he's the one that has the
very strong hatred of the orange glove
so we're just going to leave him to
settle for a
minute but we might see if rain will
come over real quick hey rain rain oh
good boy really good no not you Lou that
was very
rude okay I'm going to grab you because
L is not being very polite so rain's
been on his nest all morning just
defending his chick so he just ate a v
fish uh so now he's coming out for some
breakfast and we'll see if he likes his
no he says gross these are lak smell and
I really don't want them so I'm probably
going to put him down and let him maybe
go take care of his chick again right
now rain's being a great dad this year
good
boy rescued animals become family to
Wildlife Conservation staff oh there we
go there's some nursing with a little
luck and a lot of TLC creatures big and
small get a second chance to
flourish this is the Pinnacle of what we
want to do with our lives is really be a
part of conservation just to know that
the future of that calf is going to help
the wood bison that are out there it's
hard to describe that but it's very
humbling and it's just Ultra
[Music]
rewarding